considering the the school
representative representative already
finished the surgeon searching at the
campus and informed the police state
about the situation in the campus so our
safety team together with some kind
offices will enter the school tomorrow
morning there are two purpose for the
safety team to handle the dangerous item
and offensive offensive weapons like
petrol bombs and corrosive liquids and
also to gather evidence for the
extensive damage inside the school
the school has added stage homers to
join us to visit visit the school again
and search the school tomorrow our work
will be more efficient with their
assistance in conclusion we will
continue to maintain the coast
communication with the school management
we make our decisions based on our human
humanitarian concerns and also we adopt
a peaceful method and festival approach
to solve the problem our ultimate goal
is to restore the safety of the campus
and to reopen the campus as soon as
possible it is our response pretty to
handle all the dangerous item found
inside the campus and a finish the
evidence gathering at the scene before
handing over the school to the
management
you